[Music]
wow
hello there fortnite chapter 4 season 3
is ending and a huge Interstellar
telescope has been erected a quick thank
you if I may I'm sorry I've been away
for so long but a huge thank you to
those who continue to support me whilst
I was useless you're amazing right now
it's time to convert two and a half
months into 10 minutes so sit your butt
down and let's do this
after an entire city fell from the sky
and we've casually reunited the Clans
something unprecedented happened the
ground beneath our feet Shook and a
little crack appeared okay it was more
than a little crack an entire ancient
civilization was found below us things
down here were dormant and nature began
to reclaim it without warning an old
face appeared none other than Dr Sloan
the former IO operative who we once
fought side by side with to thwart an
alien invasion the very same woman who
left us for dead exploding UFO with us
inside she can't be trusted down here
Sloane lives alone within a makeshift
Camp around an old IO tank the very same
one she was in when this happened
[Music]
um
look out we thought we'd never see her
again how wrong we were the new biome
has one very surprising change the
vaulted zero point the place the Big
Bang happened is now petrified and by
the looks of it totally useless
elsewhere multiple vaults and temples
appeared and one held another surprise
the Sigil of the Autobots was located a
mysterious Vault for the Transformers no
less and we instantly made contact with
their leader who decided to use car
radios to communicate with us
greetings my name is Optimus Prime
if you are hearing this message
time has come to make your escape this
reality is doomed to collapse but hope
is not yet lost
listen and
move
it's only day one of this new season and
we've been told our reality is doomed to
collapse we have about 10 weeks to save
it or make our Escape but before any of
that can happen we have a treasure hunt
to go on as Aura tasks us to find a
relic once used by Aurelia the Golden
Queen of fortnite Legend we track down
the terribly named Chalice of
kubetastrophy and hand it over where it
is safely stored away from untrustworthy
people this may be nothing but the
person set to look after this artifact
isn't revealed just a contact maybe a
collector oh and while hunting for this
chalice to our surprise the notes we
needed we stole from Sloan so maybe
we're the Bad Guys
thank you
the second week of the new season and we
began to learn more about Sloane's new
Mission seemingly she has left the
imagined order behind and set herself
the task of understanding this ancient
civilization and their motivations
Sloane begins to work with a group
called The Luminaries a set of explorers
sent into the jungle by the Clans we
saved last season which honestly seems
like a lifetime ago the leader of this
Expedition is Trace who is very
knowledgeable about this new old world a
secret side quest Sora is collecting
these teardrop prisms and returning them
to trace who believes they are part of
the apparatus this wrecked piece of
equipment on the roof of this building
is somehow important to him and so too
Sloan Sloan and Trace build a mutual
relationship driven by their pursuit of
the same goals to rebuild whatever this
piece of apparatus is but Sloane also
left recordings and pretty much confirms
she's using The Luminaries for their
resources to get her own way
to excavate the site I can get the
apparatus working Sloan tells us of a
person who saved her after her fall from
the tank months ago it's quite vague and
it could honestly be anyone from Optimus
Prime to any of the mythical beings
we've met over the years but the
likelihood is this guy Relic a new NPC
patrolling the ruins ready to fight
anyone who Ventures too close we know so
little about his motivations but we do
know how easy he is to aggravate and
that he can teleport shot distances so
trace and The Luminaries make a deal
with him stay out of our way and we'll
stay out of yours this week we also
received another message from Optimus
Prime telling us to trust Sloan listen
for yourself
contact with the one you call Sloan and
while she may be an unlikely Ally
she alone knows the path forward so I
guess we're told just to go with the
flow Optimus can definitely be trusted I
am coming
week three arrived and that leader of
the Transformers once again was back
telling us about the lost power of the
zero point and the only way to escape
being located in the stars the power
that once flowed through your island has
faded and formidable enemies have taken
notice the answers you seek
lie deep within the starless boy that
brought you here every everything was
pointing at helping Sloane and The
Luminaries build that oversized
telescope so we went back to collecting
prisms of kinetic energy again oh and
week three also saw the annual summer
event kickoff completely derailing any
story as everyone became friends and had
a pool party we needed to wait a
fortnight for fortnite story to return
week five of the wild season hit and the
map updated with the focus of the
luminary spreading their makeshift roads
span further than ever before as trace
and Sloan continue to work to rebuild
the apparatus a side quest appeared this
week starring Triggerfish who I've just
noticed catches a lot of weapons and
trailers he asked us to find and protect
the coral bodies so finally after years
the wobbly blobs have a little piece of
law as this lady sets up a task force to
protect them from harm long story short
Turk planned to sell the coral bodies to
a wealthy collector but no name is given
again I wonder if this is the same
person as Aura was talking about weeks
earlier the mission ends with the freed
wobbly blobs having a dance party on the
beach very wholesome back over to Sloan
who had continued her Research into the
ancient civilization unearthing many
carvings and murals the fortnite
community tried to understand them with
claims that the projector on the roof
could be used to go back and forwards in
time all my personal favorite is that
this image here could represent the
return of the last reality's Cube cradle
AKA The Floating testicle yeah that's
not a good name Sorry
by the sixth week of the season the
spread of the luminary's reach was
honestly quite impressive the tiny
updates saw new makeshift buildings
erected and one in particular over at
creepy compound was pounced on by the
community a desk had files upon it and
take a closer look they're all stamped
with Stark Industries the home of Tony
Stark and his many Iron Man suits this
could be seen as just reused assets or
maybe a teaser about the return of the
man in metal I guess we'll see elsewhere
Futurama's cast crash-landed into Mega
City their ship embedded in the Titan
Tron here
week 7 arrived with another crossover
Jujutsu Cason which I've never heard of
before but I'm sure that's really
awesome to someone out there but I've
got to admit those llamas do look way
better in this style oh and Optimus was
back this week taking over our car radio
when my favorite song was on
[Applause]
the key to your future lies in the past
you must raise the unknown is it just me
or does that seem to say we are going
back in time in a future season I'm so
down for that but wait something else
was uncovered this week triac knocks the
villain of Mega City last season had
returned and should we interact with era
and NPC from this season's battle pass
she'll say this I know you're hiding
from Treyarch Aurora but even you cannot
stop the dawn okay so a bit of
backtracking last season we translated
triac knocks his name to realize it
means night and Treyarch is another way
to say three rulers this new information
now tells us that triac Aurora is the
second of the three their names Knox and
Aurora translate from Latin into English
as night and Dawn suggesting the three
rulers watching over us are related to
the path of the sun as after Darkness
fall calls a new dawn begins
week 8 is here and the final update of
fortnite season 4 arrived with it and at
last a mission for Sloan herself we
somehow have once again become her
subordinate like the old days and that
didn't end too well for us but anyway
Sloan tells us about the secret vault
hidden under sheets of ice and within it
is a schematic needed for the apparatus
to function so we navigate a Maze Before
acquiring this a blueprint for some sort
of kinetic or and get this it belonged
to Rift Ward and stellen if you can cast
your mind far enough back to season one
of the chapter stellen built a rift gate
to try and open a path to other worlds
and the sky kind of blew up I'll link
that season's recap if you want to know
more about stellen and his nightmares
Sloane is ready to take the rift
warden's work forward and asks us to dig
up old refined R to Cobble together
enough energy to operate and supercharge
the apparatus we get it done like the
lap dogs we are and activate the Stellar
projector a point to know here is that
Sloan doesn't do this herself she's
fallen out with The Luminaries and now
sits in the shadows as we do her bidding
the final piece of information we
receive is the key to the new season
there's no way the people who
Beyoncé
unless it's happened before the eclipse
is the key
the eclipse is the key so maybe the
three rulers theory is coming sooner
than we think
as we approach the final days of the
season the Stellar projector will
continue to evolve plotting a course in
the skies above our heads and
simultaneously counting down to the
impending Eclipse which brings the new
season which could change the very
fabric of time and space Optimus Prime
told us 10 weeks ago that this island
will not survive and Escape is our only
option he said to trust in Sloan and her
plan and we did that he also implied
traveling through time is possible and
our next steps lie in the past what will
happen next would you like to have a
guess before the season begins if not I
have one question for you can we really
trust Sloan I'm Adam you're awesome it's
been a pleasure it's good to be back
I'll see you next time
[Music]